.
- Oui, parce qu'il y en a,
de l'espoir, quand même.
- Il y en a.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Une terre sèche, brûlée
par le soleil. Un environnement
qui ne pardonne pas.
À Kargi, au nord du Kenya,
il fait 40 degrés à l'ombre.
Alors, le puits de Ririma
offre un peu de répit.
Point de convergence
des troupeaux, engagés dans
une incessante ruée vers l'eau.
(bêlements)
La vie, ici, s'organise autour
du puits. Ibrahim Buroya gère
le trafic, essaie de s'assurer
qu'il y ait assez d'eau pour
tous les animaux assoiffés.
(propos en swahili)
Autrefois fiable, la terre
nourricière montre aujourd'hui
des signes évidents de faillite.
La sécheresse actuel e est
d'une durée et d'une intensité
sans précédent.
Et les conséquences
sont terribles.
Ibrahim ne fait pas exception.
Son cheptel n'est plus
aujourd'hui qu'un tas d'os.
♪ ♪ ♪
(bêlement)
Dans la région, des dizaines
de milliers d'animaux ont
succombé en quelques semaines
seulement.
♪ ♪ ♪
Clairement, ici, on est
aux premières loges
des changements climatiques.
Les données scientifiques
ne mentent pas.
Dans certaines régions du nynya,
les températures moyennes ont
déjà augmenté de deux degrés.
Plus inquiétant encore :
Dame Nature se fait
imprévisible. Les épisodes météo
extrêmes se multiplient.
♪ ♪ ♪
Il suffit de se rendre
à Hurri Hills pour enoioir
les conséquences. Connue
pour ses collines verdoyantes
et ses riches pâturages,
cette région du rdrd du Kenya a
toujours eu des airs de paradis.
♪ ♪ ♪
Mais Roba Bora n'aime pas
y revenir. L'endroit, pour lui,
est maudit.
♪ ♪ ♪
Car c'est ici que son troupeau
de près de 500 moutons, chèvres
et chameaux, a été décimé...
en une seule nuit.
L'uvuvre d'une vie,
oblitérée en un instant.
Roba Bora ne comprend toujours
pas ce qui s'est passé.
Une tornade, sans doute.
Du jamais-vu dans la région.
Tout comme d'ailleurs
les inondations soudaines,
en pleine saison sèche,
qui ont noyé, un peu plus loin,
des milliers de bêtes.
Un drame infini dans une culture
où la richesse se mesureen nomb.
Le vieil homme n'a plus
la force de recommencer.
Il ne souhaite aujourd'hui plus
qu'une chose : pouvoir garder
ses enfants à l'école le plus
longtemps possible, gage,
selon lui, d'une vie meilleure.
Comme lui, des populations
entières d'éleveurs dépendent
aujod'd'hui de la générosité
de leurs voisins ou de l'aide
humanitaire.
(brouhaha de voix au loin)
L'ONG locale PACIDA,
par exemple, est très active
sur le terrain.
Mais l'eau reste la clé.
Et les points de distribution,
comme celui-ci, alimentés
par camions citerne, sont
clclairement insuffisants.
♪ ♪ ♪
♪ ♪ ♪ ♪
Les conséquences n'ont pas fini
de se faire sentir. Déjà,
la sécheresse mène à l'exode
et à des conflits armés.
Ibrahim Buroya, lui, l'a déjà
compris : l'élevage, ici,
n'a plus beaucoup d'avenir.
En fait, c'est tout le mode
de vie nomade qui est menacé.
Alors, il prévoit
se débarrasser de ses derniers
animaux et ouvrir une boutique
pour vendre des produits
de première nécessité.
La seule solution, selon lui,
est de s'adapter, car la planète
n'a pas fini de se réchauf